break out the banana hammock that's
coming to vegas
let's serve up some news sunny side up
we're gonna start the news with what
people are freaking out about
it's a hot new filter on instagram and
it's called
pillow face um and yahoo life reports
that it transforms your face to show you
what you would look like if you went
straight to filler town and
went a little banana all right so
take a look at these pics um actress uh
ashley benson uh posted one sophie
turner went to this and
lily collins also joined in on the fun
and the filter was started for fun but
it's become a very strong visual way
of you know talking about extremes
injectables plastic surgery uh ross and
i took it for a spin
yeah i'm opposed to this um but i
secretly kind of want to look like this
oh drew by the way i look like my mother
and jocelyn wildenstein
i love chuck beauty crew reports that
green
is the new color on everyone's lids
here's issa rae
lucy hale and zendaya rocking
emerald eyes now xana for people who
want to go green
give us some tips some pro tips on how
to approach it
whether you're going to go minimalist or
maximalist i think minimalist is the way
forward this
a little goes an awfully long way
i love the idea of just a liner right in
sweden instead of a black eyeliner
choose a green i love these ones we have
here we have a plethora of green in
front of us
so this flower beauty great green
eyeliner you can pop it on the top lid
just in the water line maybe alone not
even on the top one is a really good
look
kick it out to the side a graphic
floating eye if you want you don't
have to do a full-on shadow and also
it's good rule of thumb when you're
picking which green you want to wear as
well
wow if you have like a cool skin tone
it's good to wear
one of the cooler greens which would be
apple colored lime
colored mint colored if you have a
warmer skin tone
these ones are great like the olives
they're more foresty green
usa today reports that hbo max and
channing
tatum are teaming up for a new series to
find the real
magic mic it's a reality competition
show and they'll take
a cast of real men who have lost their
magic
and transform them into sexy confident
magic mics
chris appleton i just have to say why is
this taking so long it's always women
getting a makeover
what do you think absolutely it's about
time the men got a piece of the action i
think
yep by the way chris appleton are you
the real magic mike
i don't know not really
even when you're you look that good if
you don't have the confidence you can't
pull it off and i think that's what
they're going to be looking for in this
series which is why i'm announcing now
i'm going to be auditioning thank you so
much
out the banana hammock is coming to
vegas
glamour reports that there's a new blush
hack making the rounds that gives your
face a real
facelift and mian i would love for you
to show us how to do this because
let's face it who doesn't want a face
left honestly blush can be used in so
many different ways
i have this one here this is nectar
blush bomb by flower
and you can do a lot of different things
with blush so you can actually contour
your face with it so i'm going to take a
little bit on a brush here
and if you put your blush just on the
apple of the cheek
which is a totally fine thing to do you
end up with a little
bit of a flush but if you take your
blush you can always put your finger
here
and actually lift it up the cheekbone
and that just instantly lifts your face
without even having to use
contour products right i'm into this
mian
i really really really am and i have to
say one side of my face
totally does look higher than the other
right this one right here
it worked no totally
thank you thank you
pop sugar reports that you can now get
do booby tape pink clay mask a skin care
product for your tattoos
and it's designed to clear up impurities
blemishes and moisturize your little
round pals
krista thoth
look your skin doesn't stop here i mean
why not
bring it on down the girls need love too
i completely agree and all the
top skin care specialists in the world
which i've been lucky enough to have
access to a bunch of them
they are like literally do your skin
care routine
with like a tank top on um you know or a
bando so that you don't
forget about this area so let's take it
a little lower
and just i'm i'm all for it i'm game i'd
like to try it i am too and a lot of
times
the the chest area you can see aging
right
dude decolletage tells all
[Music]
[Applause]
there he goes and today
in honor of our very first day of beauty
week it's a special product from
my very own line flower beauty i am
obsessed everybody it is our petal
pout lip scrub now you open it up
and you put your finger in and i'm not
kidding you can put it right on
over your lipstick to sort of melt it
off
but i also love to put it on when i have
no lipstick at all and then leave it on
and i'm not kidding you
don't be surprised if you find yourself
doing this
it's so delicious it tastes so good okay
hello
okay for starters it feels like you're a
sugar scrub right yeah getting a dead
skin and it tastes so delish
and you can get kissable lips for just
10 bucks and it should taste delicious
and be a total pleasure to have the
experience this is a game changer